all the positive emotion we feel
that uh except for the type that is just
a consequence of basic satisfaction you
know the sort of satisfaction you might
have after a big meal all the enthusiasm
and excitement and hope and curiosity
essential meaning in life all of that
all of that is experienced in
relationship to a goal when you see
yourself moving towards a goal
then you're inspired you have you have
hope you have enthusiasm you have energy
um you can communicate effectively and
enthusiastically no goal you have none
of that no vision no goal
so
you're not going to get tired and and
feel what would you say hard done by if
your sacrifices and the difficult things
that you're endeavoring to do are
clearly worthwhile by your own
definition